[Musica]
sto aspettando mi ritorni la memoria
prof
beh mai capitato di prepararvi per un
esame una lezione andare lì davanti
salire e non ricordarvi esattamente una
massa di niente come a me adesso ragazzi
facile facile dite voi ma mi sono sempre
chiesto come qualcuno riesca a
raggiungere i propri obiettivi e qualcun
altro mai anche un sogno è un obiettivo
certo nella sua forma più emotiva
obiettivo di cui spesso abbiamo un
chiaro punto d'arrivo ma spesso manca
una visione d'insieme o di partenza
voi avete obiettivi avete sogni chiusi
nel cassetto nascosti sotto l'armadio in
gas in soffitta e oggi ne ho molti
obiettivi e sogni ma ancor prima di
poterli realizzare di combattere per
realizzarli ho dovuto capire comprendere
imparare contro cosa e chi combattere
perché vedete tra il dire e fare non c'è
di mezzo il mare
ci siamo noi il primo ostacolo siamo noi
il vero grande problema sono le
abitudini e iper in three che ci hanno
ci siamo costruiti attorno tutto attorno
a noi che vodafone ragazzi a un pivello
in confronto ciao a te sono elia e
volevo fare il bassista rock in un
gruppo rock con il nemico sami cantante
rock e così è stato almeno per un po
ancora mi vedo con i miei sedici anni
senza un franco un quattrino come si
disse qua in romagna per potermi
comprare neanche una custodia per il mio
strumento musicale a girare da una
stazione all'altra perché sapete una
volta se voleva incontrare una persona o
tu andavi da lei o lei veniva da te e
quindi a girare da una stazione
all'altra stretto stretto al mio basso
elettrico portato a tracolla ma sulla
schiena quasi forse un arco
di cui le frese volevano essere le mie
note che quando potevo sparavo dritte
dritte al cuore di chi mi stava
ascoltando perché mi piace più dare che
ricevere e volevo emozionare in sentivo
una sorta di robin hood del
compiacimento piacere troppo agli altri
ricordatevi che non va mai troppo bene
quasi a nascondere a non voler svuotarmi
delle mie emozioni per darli agli altri
sapete 30 anni fa perché il bambino qui
presente né al 50 belin le cose erano
leggermente diverse
non esisteva internet non esistevano i
social eni anche queste notifiche del
cavolo esistevano i posti e le persone
facebook la scuola la piazzetta la
panchina sotto casa
instagram l'apparire la discoteca link
per i più grandicelli bay gli affari lo
sapete si facevano al bar bene o male
tutti e noi e li dai posti e le persone
da un idea su di una panchina
dalle prove nel garage fa suonare nei
bar nei pub nei club e poi nelle
discoteche fino al grande hall non posto
all'oracolo la televisione vogliamo
andare in tv
sapete andare in tv i tempi non era
affatto facile era come essere un super
astronauta sulla luna e noi sulla luna
per lo meno non è la parte più
illuminata ma c'eravamo arrivati
eh sì se eravamo arrivati non certo per
suonare ma eravamo lì con un marco
predolin come conduttore e una federica
panicucci ai tempi poco più che teenager
come valletta tre allegri ragazzi
romagnoli a un contest televisivo il
gioco delle coppie a vi sembra facile
visto in bra poco
fatelo voi belen dopo quell'evento
non vi dico
tornati eravamo degli influencer mezza e
fu fantastico perché le opportunità
fioccarono addirittura si fu un 45 giri
che ancora fare un 45 giri i tempi
ragazzi ma te la devo dire e potevo
continuare a tirare le mie note le mie
frecce sempre più lontano poi però
arrivarono tutte a me dritte dritte al
cuore con un nome sulla punta un cognome
nella stecca e un viso sulla più ma una
chiamata nelle prime ore della mattina e
non una chiamata di quelle che ti salva
la vita
e lì è morto matri
il chitarrista del gruppo assieme lui
altri quattro ragazzi erano partiti per
novellara per modena per fare una jam
session sapete una jam session sono
musicisti di più gruppi che si
riuniscono e suono improvvisano mi
ricordo ancora la sera prima
prima di partire mentre stava per salire
su quella macchina appoggiato su quella
golf grigia eravamo cesenatico alla sala
giochi sotterranea arriva una chiamata e
lì per te ciao sono maura vengo giù a
cesenatico ci sei
se li felipe da fare eccomi qui perché
io
da lì a poco tanto il primo batterista
del gruppo morì anche lui in un
incidente stradale
ora sono qui con me nel mio cuore
e parliamo anche fu l'inizio di un
brutto periodo noto alle cronache anche
come le stragi del sabato sera e sentire
di quei ragazzi morti in queste
settimane sulla strada fa male e mi
riapre ferite che non si sono mai margin
a te certo con un dolore occhi
differenti quelli di un padre fu così
gli anni 80 un casino
e fu così che il mio sogno rock si
frantuma in mille pezzi di vetro su cui
io dovevo imparare a camminare non ne
avevo assolutamente voglia ragazzi stare
in una band come in un gruppo di lavoro
come in una scuola come in tante cose fa
sì che si creano dei rapporti dove
condividi tutto soprattutto anche i
disagi primo consiglio parlate a voi più
piccinini ma anche ai grandi parlate
parlate con chi vi sta vicino con chi vi
ama non tenetevi le cose dentro e quindi
il mio sogno infranto i mille vetrine
non volerci camminare sopra d'altronde
per me il gruppo hera comunicare sapete
i tempi mi occupavo anche di fare
piccoli biglietti locandine fare poi le
fotocopie da pizzicare tutti che ancora
mi vedo l'inchiostro nelle mani fu lì
che mi dissi iniziai a parlare al mio
cuore qualcosa cambiò e v
se non puoi comunicare con la musica fa
l'ho con la grafica e così fu diventai
grafico poi diventa il programma
programmatore perché volevo che le mie
grafiche si animassero le facce dei
videogiochi dei videogame che migliaia
di condividere anche a vendere e le
persone mi chiesero ma quali logiche
usate come hai fatto a farli e iniziai a
insegna
divenni docente e eccomi qua a formatore
certo avevo risolto una parte dei
problemi
cos'è successo in quel periodo
sapete mi ero trovato con il mio sogno
rock infranto e sono riuscito a
trasformare un moto di comunicare che
non era quello più di suonare con la
grafica ma in quel momento è stato molto
dura sapete perché oltre a non avere più
dei fra a non avere più il mio sogno
rock avevo altri problemi più materiali
io vivevo di musica a pagare le bollette
pagarsi da mangiare col dispiacere non
paghi nelle bollette nel mangiare i
problemi quei simpaticoni non amano
stare da soli ai problemi piace stare
assieme e uno ne tira un altro quindi
quando ne avete uno così è in quel
periodo spot il personaggio logico di
star trek che faceva tutto con la logica
ma senza amore che in qualche maniera mi
aiutò a crearmi una sorta di coltellino
svizzero di turchi di manuali di
sopravvivenza quando rischi di cadere e
così mi dissi e lì c'è un problema a una
soluzione punto magari ti fai un po di
sbatti sbatti rinuncia qualcosa è una
soluzione ma se è un grande problema di
vidili in tanti piccoli problemi che
affronta lì proprio come fate quando
affrontato in agosto la scolastico raga
e quando non c'è soluzione perché capita
che non c'è soluzione cosa fai
tira gomitoli nella sostanza come una
palla che rimbalza da una parete
all'altra per uscire magari ogni tanto
appoggiarti con i gomiti muri su di un
muro lasciando che il mondo ti vomiti
addosso
no devi reagire
quando un problema non ha soluzione si
tratta di un'altra cosa si tratta di un
cambiamento e come tale va accettato e
gestito un cambiamento fa paura è
diametralmente opposto a un sogno un
obiettivo di cui abbiamo la visione
d'arrivo nel problema abbiamo la visione
nel cambiamento scusate una visione di
partenza ma non sappiamo dove come
andremo una signora in sala che si
chiama pina mia mamma mi ha sempre detto
è lì per una porta che ti si chiude
ci sono più portoni grandi aperti che
aspettano solo di farti entrare deve
trovarli
dicono che siamo la somma delle 75
persone che più spesso frequentiamo ai
tempi di sé a cambiare compagnia punti
di vista d'altronde se sto tutti i
giorni mi dicevo con cinque persone che
sbattono la testa contro il muro la
sbatto anche io o belen no
inizia a girare con persone che
camminano e nel cammino magarini fa
osservare e osservando cambierà i punti
di vista magari girando anche sempre
attorno alla stessa statua
avete mai fatto un giro attorno alla
stessa statua ogni volta è diversa è
così
sapete cos'è controverso il respiro è la
prima ed ultima cosa che faremo prima
del grande buio ma come nel sabato del
villaggio del leopardi non è la domenica
la festività è la preparazione come
l'uomo che scala la montagna lo
scalatore non è arrivare in cima il
viaggio è quello che è importante
ricordatevi perché questo quello che vi
voglio lasciare non è il punto d'arrivo
ma è cosa come e per chi lo farete
durante questo respiro
sapete cos'è controverso controverso è
questo
sapete cos'è controverso un posto dove
avvengono i miracoli un posto dove dai
problemi non nascono opportunità un
posto da vedo da dov'era i problemi
nascono eccellenze eccellenze nei
prodotti eccellenze nei servizi
eccellenze nelle professioni un posto
dove nascono eccellenze e luce che
brilla nel cuore negli occhi e in questo
posto ci siamo seduti dentro perché si
chiama san patrignano e a lui ilva
plauso
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no